[Applause]
we met em - calm but on our first
meeting we sat and had coffee together
and realize that we had gotten to the
same high school and grew up about a
mile from one another hi I'm Tony my
wife Katie and we live in Milwaukee
Wisconsin
I was a teacher at first and you know
made OK money never a lot I actually was
pretty impressed with myself I bought my
first home by 25 and I had a ton of
student loan debt but I definitely was
of the mindset that is a tool I actually
felt really good about what I was doing
I always felt like I was doing a good
job with money you know it was like I
would amass a good pile of debt and then
I would pay it all down you know I just
kept amassing more and more to the point
where you know it just got to be too
much finally our turning point is when
we got engaged and when we got engaged
just as part of that process we met with
a financial advisor we both went in
there thinking like we're doing so great
how can we do even better and he was
like you guys are in horrible shape like
so much debt you mean like look at this
when you combine it we wrote pretty
freaked out went home and I called my
sister and my sister said it sounds like
everything he told you I was just like
this book the Total Money Makeover I
mean from that moment on everything was
sort of put on the path we needed to be
on we've read the Total Money Makeover
so once I had sort of this plan and how
to do it all of a sudden it all just
made sense and things started clicking I
think just doing it together we were
both very much committed to this and on
the same page and usually one of us at
least recognized that it would be worth
it the I had a really nice SUV you know
and Katie had just a nice small economy
car from the nerd I looked at the
numbers and would like to us this is
goodbye
to you car but I'm smart enough to
listen to my nerd and you know it made
sense to me as well so when you know
it's the right decision even if it's
difficult I think you can still make the
sacrifice
[Music]
well we decided actually after my
daughter was born we sort of we were
making really good progress but that was
I mean it really changed the timeline
she was born you know sort of like
wonderful happy surprise sooner than we
expected just before our first
anniversary you know it was very clear
things had to change so we just were at
a point where we were feeling you know
really happy with our lives in terms of
our family but feeling frustrated cuz
we've been making so much progress with
our finances and so we went to financial
since University with her she was
obviously a baby and everything but
having her there with us at the classes
and everything I mean it was just great
motivation oh yeah you're like looking
at your reason for doing it it was
really good you know we knew the
material we've been read the book we've
been listening to the podcast but just
connecting with other people around it
and talking with them about where we
were in our journey and just kind of
reenergized us and I think that's what
we were hoping for when we went into
Financial Peace University yeah I kind
of fear that I don't push all of our
life transitions that we have had
happened to us since we magically been
married I mean have all been impacted by
our debt free journey once we became
debt free the biggest sort of life
moment happened for us when my mom
passed away and we found out that she
had lung cancer and by December she was
gone we never even used a credit card
through that so to think that we just I
mean that's what emergency fund is for
and we just kept kind of drawing from
that emergency fund and it's scary to do
that but we looked at each other and we
were like this is a true emergency like
this is exactly why you have it yeah
anam passed away and I was taking care
of my dad I mean nothing was easy but
the things we didn't have money problems
on top of it you know just made it made
it a little bit easier and manages it
it's a great thing now is really you
know looking to the future I mean it's
great to be able to look to the future
make big plans and get excited about
them and know that they are actually a
possibility we're living lives that we
want to live yeah
[Music]
you asked at the beginning how has it
change our relationship with each other
and I have to say I don't feel like it
really has because this is sort of how
we built our relationship together but
what it has changed is the way we can
relate to everyone else our daughter
his mom when she's dying you know his
dad that's the relationship that's
changed
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh
[Music]